[Music]
suppose I have a new version of my
application that's ready for launch
we've tested it and it's working well
but I'd like to ease it into production
let's see how the sto service mesh can
help us with that surface meshes like
sto allow for greater control over the
traffic and communication between each
of our applications to pull it in the
cluster is teo as an open source project
you can deploy sto on kubernetes and get
visibility automatic encryption and
advanced routing policies on your
applications
best of all your team doesn't need to
change any application code to use this
do at first we only want to send a small
percentage of the traffic say 20 percent
to the new version of our travel
application will send 80 percent of the
traffic to the existing version until
we're sure the new version is working
well for customers with sto installed on
our cluster traffic policies can be
applied the same way as kubernetes
objects using Y Amal and coop control
apply commands first we'll deploy a
version 1 and version 2 of our
applications in this scenario will use
the drones to represent a deployment and
the height of the drones to represent
the percentage of traffic being sent to
the application both drones are flying
at the same height meaning there are no
traffic rules applies we need to ensure
version 2 of the application is running
ok before we're ready to send a hundred
percent of the traffic to it and get rid
of our version 1 an sto virtual service
allows for defining rules to control
traffic flow well create a virtual
service configuration which sends 80% of
the traffic diversion 1 and 20% to
version 2
I can see how sto would become
increasingly valuable as a team needs to
manage complex relationships between
applications
besides Canary rollouts like we just saw
you can do routing based on headers
fault injection to test resiliency get
telemetry and tracing data and enforce
authentication policies thank you so
much for joining us today for this
demonstration we can't wait for the next
time
you